I really bring breathing and yoga
practices into my teaching as well
before a big day students have time to
rest review or to release and it's just
five minutes where it's quiet
this is huge engagement is more
important than compliance engagement
matters more than compliance that's the
teacher's job meet them where they're at
and then to give them everything I can
so they have more options and
opportunities in life and the students
were so grateful for how I restructured
things to give less emphasis to grades
and more emphasis to feedback and growth
and reflection the gradeless classroom
is not about transactions but
transformation and secondly the
gradeless classroom means that I have a
learning lab not a grading game and then
they make it $25,000 reward so anyhow
they called my name
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sake on we
are now going to be talking about
mindful grading and much more we have
Gina Benz joining us on the show
hi miss Bence hi Alan you can call me
Gina now miss beds used to be my AP
English teacher in high school mm-hmm
and I'm so happy that we're getting this
chance to sit down together and talk
thank you for coming on the show I think
it's gonna get deep yeah which I hope it
did when you were my student way back
and what are you graduating 2010
so probably 2008-2009 ya know ten years
ago yes high school yup and for those
who don't know Gina's background she won
a Milken educator award in October 2015
and has been teaching at Roosevelt High
School in Sioux Falls for twenty years
including AP English Language and
Composition sheltered English - teacher
pathway and used to be the AP department
chair she increased the AP English
sections at Roseville high school from
one to five and from 25 to 120 students
and you can find her links in the bio
below Gina Benz org as well as leaving
Church org and her Twitter profile I'm
so excited to be talking about all these
topics together let's jump into things
with one of our favorite questions to
ask our guests what are your thoughts on
the direction of our world when I think
about what's happening in the world I
always live by the greatest commandment
that Jesus gave us I follow the Jesus
tradition and I'm very purposeful about
saying it's the Jesus tradition because
a lot has gone wrong with Christianity
along house lot has gone wrong with the
Christian Church in America but I still
like what Jesus said in the Gospels
greatest commandment of all is to love
God to love others as we look as
ourselves there's three implications
there most people just think about
loving God and loving other
but we also have to take care of
ourselves yeah so every decision I make
when it comes to things big-picture this
world falls under love God love others
and take care of myself a little bit too
so if we're talking immigration which is
dear to my heart because I have ELL
students English learnt English Learner
students love God love others that's
going to determine how I look at things
I think there's a powerful movement in
our world toward this worldview
that follows the greatest Commandments I
also think there's an opposite group
that's moving away from it and I'm on
the side of love
it might sound wishy-washy or weak but
the power of love I've seen in my life
in my classroom so I go with it yeah the
power of love and also love God love
yourself and love others I love that
yeah and I'm very quick to say God by
any name exactly me too got people look
I'll God yeah you know that's right and
there's so many good ways to to say that
God is like the divine or it's like the
courts like creation or it's like source
or spirit there's so many ways all that
is there's so many ways to describe that
and so yeah it's however one is
communing with that that's their own
beautiful adventure of consciousness and
communion and
yes yes okay so how about this journey
into teaching so who were you growing up
and how did you get interested in this I
never wanted to be a teacher I
distinctly remember sitting in my high
school American literature class looking
around the room and thinking I could
never do this I could never teach these
crazy kids so I went to college to be a
marriage and family therapist but to do
that you have to go to grad school so
being the very practical person I am I
said well English teachers are needed
about everywhere so I'll get the English
teaching degree as a fallback second
option it didn't take long into the
program that I fell in love with the
idea of teaching it was at the time I
loved reading and writing and then also
the idea of working with students well
that has totally flip-flop since I love
who I teach I love what I teach and I
love where I teach and the who I teach
is always number one and then yeah how I
tell tell us more about when you're
first you know getting started what did
you end up where did you end up going to
start teaching and what does that
process even like well my process is
really boring and not very interesting I
have a lot of colleagues that I network
with especially through a group called
teachers going gradeless they've worked
in several different buildings over the
past 15 years or whatever I've worked in
one building so when I was graduating
from college I got a call from from a
few schools but the two I was
considering were Roosevelt High School
where we met and then Lenox High School
which is my alma mater hmm so do I go
back to my small-town hometown which was
really appealing had a wonderful
principal I would love to work for or do
I try something in the city I was living
living in I was pulled to Roosevelt it
was intriguing it felt like a great
adventure to me and I have never
regretted teaching at Roosevelt since
2000 I've taught about every English
class there is
I've settled into some English classes I
loved dearly but again mostly it's the
students I love and then how did she
then first get settled into Roosevelt
and into this idea of teaching into
these classroom sizes of what was it at
that time only maybe 25 kids in a class
and how did you get to figure out what
exactly you were gonna teach were there
curriculum requirements always said
yourself you teach what they tell you
you're gonna teach cuz you want the job
I started out with Oh quite the mix I
had freshman English I had junior
English and I had I think I also had
modern lit in there so I had three preps
which is unusual for a bigger city now
if I'd been gone to my hometown I wanna
Exide out maybe five different preps we
call them preparations preparation for a
class I had to prepare for I then had to
prepare for three classes yeah I also
was asked to be a assistant coach for
the aural entertain I knew nothing about
oral inter but I wanted the job I wanted
them happy with me so I said I was
willing to learn so at the beginning you
just do whatever so you can make the
money right have a job have some
benefits but we get paid in two ways I
learned very quickly we get paid with
money which was certainly important and
necessary but we also get paid with
happiness and I tell you what I get paid
with happiness so richly in my job now
you asked about the journey so three
years in the department chair said would
you be willing to teach AP English
language
it's the AP class for juniors said no no
way that sounds like too much right now
and I was young and my husband and I
were thinking maybe we'd be starting a
family and I was just trying to protect
my my time and my energies a couple
weeks later he came back and said nobody
else wants to teach it I need you to
teach AP English language
which I've now taught since 2003 it's
become a baby of mine but I wasn't you
know I was wise enough to do this I said
I will teach it if you give me a room
with a window
he said done that's also minor but that
was an important moment for me where I I
stood up for myself but also to have a
window in a classroom yeah it's so
important to have that natural light to
get the serotonin going right and so my
desk is right by the window so I can
feel the Sun on me so we can have
natural light not fluorescent light
there's a lot of times I turn off the
lights in my classroom and we just have
the window light those those minor
things in the classroom can make such a
big difference but you know conversely
before that I was in a room that was
windowless and there's a lot of teachers
and students in that situation and I
guess it's what economics calls for
budgets call for but it makes me sad
yeah especially when we now are seeing
more and more of the literature be clear
that this idea of nature therapy
actually decreases cortisol increases
creativity so to have rooms that are
have nature just present to be able to
turn off the lights and use natural
light to have people see where they come
from the planet instead of these just
windowless rooms to try and be creative
with fluorescent lights and whatnot it
it definitely feels more like a cage in
that sense and it doesn't feel as
productive or creative or harmonious
with where we come from and so I'm happy
that you bring you brought that to our
attention and that was one of the things
that you were like I roomed with the
window and then of the English teacher
and you know now to go with what you
said I have plants in my window to bring
in nature too obviously on a small scale
clean the air because breathing is so
important and I don't think I did this
when you were my student but I really
bring breathing and yoga
practices into my teaching as well it's
important to me before a big day
students have time to rest to review or
to release and it's just five minutes
where it's quiet and some students are
quickly finishing something that's fine
they got to get it out of their brains
so that something different can come in
their brains some of them just need to
close our eyes whatever it is I don't
care
but that's beautiful honoring what they
need five minutes mm-hmm of either just
eyes closed reflecting and we're quickly
finishing something whatever they need
to checking a cellphone because if they
have that time then they don't need to
check it later
well they might need to that's a thing
for teenagers right the cell phones
I don't ban sound the cell phones from
my room no it's my job to help students
realize the appropriate way to have cell
phones in their lives and also I feel
like if my teaching is engaging enough
cell phones won't be as much of an issue
yeah that's right and more engaging the
teachers are the with the methodologies
that we're going to talk about to that
the less likely students will get
distracted and minds will wander so how
did then the you know the first couple
of years yours because you gave us these
little techniques that you've really
started to incorporate more and we'll
get into more of them but the first
couple of years you started you know you
were picking up these different preps
that you were doing so you were learning
more about how to teach English and he
picked up AP English so then what was it
like then piecing together these these
different preps so what is it like to be
a teacher in that sense of taking this
material that you have to communicate
and have the students be able to show
that they learn the material and you
have a state in the national testing
that you have to that students have to
well I guess the AP exam is nation'
isn't it global
its global
Advanced Placement school ball now yes
yeah so how do you piece it all together
I I sit back now I've developed and
grown over the years so I'll tell you
where I am now Oh where did I start at
the very beginning I followed what my
own high school teachers did i M as my
inspiration mm-hmm
not long into me starting so maybe
around 2002 No Child Left Behind time
the district got very enthusiastic about
creating a common curriculum and
guaranteeing that all teachers were
teaching to that curriculum by then
implementing district-wide semester
tests standardized tests so curriculum
influenced what I teach but now where am
I at this point at this point I it's a
mix of doing what I can be passionate
about and I think my students can be
passionate about as well so no
disrespect to Shakespeare but I'm not
good at teaching Shakespeare I don't
have any desire to teach Shakespeare
some people some of my colleagues are
amazing at it and God bless them so I if
I can avoid it I'm not going to teach
Shakespeare but I'll teach something
that can still teach the same skills
about reading and writing listening and
speaking that's the beauty of English is
what we need our students to learn is
not Romeo and Juliet it's literary
analysis mm-hmm it's the use of
figurative language
it's irony symbolism and you can do that
with any literature so now I try to
choose literature that I think will
ignite passion for me and for them and I
think of myself like a physician who has
patience and I look at their symptoms
and then I need to make a diagnosis and
issue or write a prescription and so no
year is ever the same because
the students are always different and
what's happening in the world is
different so this year in my AP class
and my EE L class because I try to do
the same thing with AP and EE L we are
going to be writing reading blind-spot
which talks about explicit biases and
implicit biases because we need to know
more about that that's huge in this
world right now I love the book I think
they will - did I answer that question
dude yeah yeah so I love the way that
you view it as this analogy to doctors
and patients and and symptoms and
prescriptions and so when there's
different learning styles then there's
different ways of you meaning the
students at where they're at and helping
them gain the literary skills that they
need in the level of the teaching that
you're passing on yes I once had a
sophomore teacher say to me what do my
what do I need to make sure the students
can do before they come to you and I
said just do the best you can with them
and I will meet them where they're at
that's the teachers job meet them where
they're at and and then to give them
everything I can so they have more
options and opportunities in life that's
the vision yeah yep give them more
options and opportunities in life more
degrees of freedom to pursue when their
gifts are so then how do you pick out of
all the different literature that exists
how do you then pick the books that you
think are going to inspire the kids the
most you know where you're at and where
they're at and so every year you've had
different books that you've been playing
with and tell us about that problem well
of course you know budget budgets
influence this a little bit so we have
to work within budgets I like to have a
mix of classical American literature
because I think students should be
well-rounded to some extent and be aware
of these things in our culture and our
history so I've always taught the great
gatsby and I think it's incredibly
pertinent because of when we're talking
about class structure it's just huge
class structure is so important now
I give my soon as a choice between The
Scarlet Letter and The Grapes of Wrath
and I love teaching both of those books
but I like to give my students choice as
much as possible because they'll take
more ownership of their learning Grapes
of Wrath oh gosh you know so much about
capitalism and what that means for our
nation great discussions come out of
that and then the Scarlet Letter
extremism is a good conversation that
comes from that and my favorite lesson
from The Scarlet Letter is that we might
do think we might mess things up or we
might do things that aren't acceptable
but we can take those things and then do
better for other people so there's
something I regret in my life I'm I need
to share that with others to help them
avoid it or share that so the others who
have the same regret know that they're
not alone mm-hmm so those you know
scarlet letter was written in 1850 but
it is still so pertinent and how many
scarlet letters do we put on people
still today mm-hmm right trans kids
right now big time yeah so the classic
stuff is important but I also do more
modern stuff I love Malcolm Gladwell
love Malcolm Gladwell's work so we read
outliers we're doing blind-spot a Raisin
in the Sun that's a good one about white
privilege and how property and
discrimination and racism connect mm-hmm
that's such a wide array of
thought-provoking books yeah I want a
wider area and you know what I hope you
noticed that I'm trying to represent I'm
trying to have a lot of different
authors right I don't want the here's
the cliche dead
guys okay there's some of them because I
grow some good stuff John Steinbeck one
of my favorites ever but Lorraine
Hansberry died way too young and she had
so much to say Malcolm Gladwell oh gosh
I hope he keeps writing for a long time
yeah so then how does how do you then do
something like take the students that
are at their different levels and they
have what you're presenting to them with
this curriculum of literature that you
think is gonna unlock their abilities to
see the world in new ways and become
better readers for literary analysis all
these types of things and then how do
you make sure that those lessons get
communicated through the literature
through their experiences reading it the
methodologies that yeah lots of
reflection my favorite way to start
classes by having students write for
eight minutes about what we just read or
what they most recently read in the book
we're reading together sharing together
you know some choice is good for
students but it's also good to share a
book in community and hear one another's
perspectives on that look so for them to
start by just reflecting and writing and
then to move to a small group to talk
about what they wrote and share what
they wrote then they get to kind of test
their ideas on someone else in a safer
environment so my classroom set up same
as it was when you're my student in
little pods of four so groups of four
and you know three sometimes get
together and share what they've
reflected on and then we move to the
whole group and each group shares
something from their small group
discussion and this is my discussion
based classroom and a method I call one
two three so we start at the one the
individual reflection to small group
three whole group and what are the time
so eight minutes for the one so those
one and then what do that how long do
they do for the two I'll just give you
estimates because it needs to be organic
right if they are engaged because this
is huge
- in teaching engagement is more
important than compliance engagement
matters more than compliance so if
they're engaged I'm gonna lie to keep
they're gonna keep talking right so I
have to be constantly present with my
students and listening as I walk around
and let them talk I can't run to my desk
and grade some papers quickly mm-hmm
because number one I hate grading papers
but number two I want to be 100% present
with my students when they are in my
room with me yeah so I'm not gonna check
an email quick I'm gonna be with them so
but roughly an estimate uh eight to ten
minutes each
well eight minutes for the reflection
eight to ten minutes for the small group
and then the large group discussion
could go the rest one year okay okay and
then how did then you make sure that
like if the student is you know barely
able to complete their own reflection or
they're not really engaging with the
group too much or the
when the big discussion section at the
end how does a teacher ensure that the
student is able to you know persevere
through the literacy this is a term we
call differentiation so I have to be in
tune with where the students are at as
best I can
so maybe I'm reading the paragraphs
they've been writing maybe I'm just
listening to the small group discussions
but when a student seems to be
struggling with analyzing interpreting
the text then I need to make a personal
connection with that student one of my
mantras in my classroom is to connect
and reflect I want to connect with every
student and we need to do constant
reflection constant connection with each
other really student a student teachers
student connect and reflect so I guess I
can't tell you what the one method is
because it's different for every student
I figure out where we're struggling and
write a prescription to fix that yeah so
for some students maybe I give them a
resource that will help them better
understand things maybe I gives them
some tips to reading critically maybe I
have them come in after school and we
have a one-on-one conversation okay yes
so it's totally dynamically adjusting
per where the student is at okay okay so
let's that's been a good amount of
methodology I think we did a pretty
decent job on you explaining at the
beginning there's also that period of
meditation reflection yogic is that the
awareness that also have to do with the
compassionate anxiety classroom work
that you do yeah yeah it was now I'm
feeling like I need to go into it like a
yoga pose to do it so I'm gonna OH
do this
I do this a lot because we sit too much
don't we yeah I'm excited this year to
tell my students and I don't know why
this dawned on me and my 20th year that
they can get out of their desk anytime
they want and sit on the floor in a
different way that's great stretch your
body yeah and if they're doing it for
the purpose of being more focused and
they are more focused by all means yes
yeah
and I found that when I give students
that dignity and respect that I trust
them and give them that freedom they
return they respond as as they should I
think teachers sometimes fear they'll
doze off or be distracted when we take
them out of the desk I'll tell you
something else that is very important to
me when it comes to student dignity
students do not need to ask me to use
the restroom it's huge yeah it's huge in
my in my opinion something as simple as
that ya know I don't be gone for 25
minutes respect it yeah yeah and don't
three people go at the same time
although sometimes that's okay because
you know someone just got a text that
grandpa died something like that but
this I just I guess it depends on the
age level right I'm not gonna judge
other grade levels but I teach mostly
11th graders and 12th graders and they
know when to use the bathroom and when
they're in college they're not gonna ask
a professor if they can use the bathroom
yeah so I always prefer to teach this
but the students figure out how to do
these things appropriately rather than
having so many rules and policies yeah
anyhow I just think it's a huge human
dignity it's like mindful teaching this
is really it's like mindful grading
which we'll talk about but this is a lot
of this is mindful to why why do you say
it's mindful teaching because you're you
have a meta perspective on being behind
your students eyes like that
you gave this example like you're giving
all these examples like they could be
getting a message that their family
member has passed but just seriously
absolutely two years ago yeah yeah that
happens so does a student wanting to
stand up and stretch their body a little
bit they may have been injured in a
sport recently or whatever that that
they're later in their life they're not
gonna be asking their employers or their
college professors can I go to the
bathroom so it's it's your what you're
doing is you're trusting them and
respecting them and giving them
independence this funny I'm literally
listing the trick pedagogy of Esther
Wojcicki who we had on the show
Oh evaporation and kindness are the last
one trust respect independence
collaboration and kindness and what
you're doing is you're like you said it
actually ends up yielding results too
because then they go I'm not in a strict
little tiny set of of limited movement
and opportunity but I have I can be my
own sovereign individual in dispensed
classroom and then I'm going to respond
by being a good student to keep those
privileges that's the exact kind of it's
a trust and a respect that we build
between each other right
I don't demand that their respect I just
care about them and love them and that
yields the right results we started
talking about how did you bring this up
you'll know you're doing the exact class
and anxiety and class and compassion
stuff like where is that kind of where
those things happen like the more that
you open up their degrees of sovereignty
then yeah yeah well anxiety is a big
anxiety and depression are a big deal in
our high schools now
really most of our behavioral issues are
probably stemmed from mental illness of
some sort some very serious right
bipolar but you know all of its serious
yeah I all of it is serious so why this
has increased is not I don't know
there's other people can speculate about
that but it has maybe it's always been
that way but now we have words for it I
don't
but anxiety is a big deal for my
students I had a student last year who
knew she had the freedom to get up and
go to the bathroom when her anxiety was
mmm at a high and she probably went to
the bathroom every single class period
at one point so yeah she can go the
bathroom breathe a little bit yeah
come back and be ready to learn and it's
also this is a big deal to when not
every single student is is extreme on
the extraversion psychometric and so
when you're cramming 30 of them into a
classroom one after the other literally
there's no time for the independence
like yeah reflection and so if a student
is having like yo I need to be my own
bubble it's like I can at least go to
the bathroom when there's nobody else in
the halls at least limited amount of
people in the halls to connect what I'm
feeling or yeah you want to know about
my dream school yeah okay let's hear
school has a room that's dark silent
except for maybe water sound nature
sounds something soft comfortable
comfortable furniture in it and students
and teachers can go there when they just
need a moment of silence and so there
might be a few in the room but no
talking whatsoever just a you know it's
kind of like how hospitals have chapels
a lot right same concept just where
something people can go and be this and
I think that I realized this because the
school I'm at where you graduated from
is at 2500 students and we really should
be at 2,000 or below we we are
overcrowded and teachers don't have
their classroom for their planning time
they go to a common area so teachers
never have a time to be alone okay but
students really don't even moreso and I
just I wish we had a place now this
would also be beneficial for our Muslim
students when they if they want to pray
yeah yeah because right now they end up
going in a counselor's office or it it's
awkward yeah
if people say there's not prayer in
school this is this is massive I'm glad
you're bringing up this idea of what
would be an ideal dream school what
could catalyze the students to find
their unique gifts and express
themselves out their best in the school
when we had Brian and Teresa on the show
from the Sioux Falls School District we
went deep into what would be an ideal
school design its des Jefferson's yeah
high school it's coming up and I don't
know 20 22 I think it will open in 21
yeah and so the when the schools is
these designs are being you know
contemplated like what well lots of
natural light lots of trees lots of
space lots of dark rooms these types of
things that enable students to feel like
they're connecting to nature while
they're at school no classroom should be
windowless should they and this is like
you're developing photos the old school
things it doesn't really make sense to
have a dark classroom for anything so
and you can also take the choice of just
closing all the blinds and making it
dark when you want versus yeah yeah it
cetera so there's all these different
ideas for designing more optimal schools
and so I'm glad that you brought them to
attention what is that you have got
these yes a beautiful thing happened
this past school year homecoming we had
our dress-up days and one day was a
career you want to be in the future so I
dressed up as a yoga teacher and I don't
know if I ever want to be a yoga teacher
actually because I like just being a
student sometimes mm-hmm a lot of times
when it comes to yoga but I thought
maybe maybe when I'm retired I'll give
free yoga classes something anyhow
my students then realized man she really
does love yoga so I started to ask can
we do some yoga with you of course yeah
yeah
now there's still people who feel like
yoga's our religion it's not especially
not in America
means Union in Sanskrit union with the
divine okay yeah okay everybody well but
it's that's the but the point is that
it's everyone's the own unique divine
journey with that process and it's not
something that's dogmatic and it's also
not Western like you're in yoga pants
stretching in the studio type thing yes
yes yeah you're right
so yogic practices are pretty big deal
in schools it's only growing right but
to what extent and I don't think poses
are the important thing but it's the
mindfulness it's quieting the mind and
recognizing the breath gaining control
of the breath again
our breath is such a beautiful thing
Ellen yeah because our bodies will do it
for us automatically but we also have
the power to control it and so it's with
us all the time and it acts as a
focusing mechanism yes yeah train your
focus and then that focus will carry
into every single aspect of our lives
families our friends our work yes of
things so my first step is to teach my
kids how to breathe yeah you know I say
breathe in try to do five five seconds
and five seconds out now try six and so
the breathing and maybe some simple
stretching or hoses we do well anyhow I
had this one AP class who just ate it up
loved it didn't feel awkward at all and
most all of them would join in and you
know would randomly say can we do yoga
today can we please do yoga they would
beg for it and if I felt like there was
time we would do it and I got a say for
any principals watching it was totally
legitimate cuz AP students need to know
how to relax to perform on a test okay
but it's just good for life right we
know that yeah so yeah we'll take ten
minutes to do something well it got to
be so much I said every Friday we're
only gonna do Friday's now Friday will
be yoga Friday they started planning
their outfits so they could do yoga
Friday yeah
and one girl said she hadn't she was in
the hospital she was out of school for
maybe a week I think because of some
things going on when she came back she
said I used what you taught me in the
hospital because I was really scared
oh it's beautiful yeah that's old it
yeah so you know no kid is forced to
some kids chose to just stay in their
desk yeah okay yeah as long as they're
quite respectable yeah exactly
but to provide it as an option is so
critical and to have that be something
that younger people are starting to
embody so that when they're faced with
adversity it's not this immediate urge
to react but this ability to slow down
breathe analyze the scenario stay calm
like that's super applicable again to
family friends co-workers all of school
and all of school it's just such a so
legitimate I could defend it to the end
of the earth yeah I love it
I love it and I think what may be a
counter to this would be is like oh well
these minutes are so precious we should
be you know jamming more information
into their and minds in that time but
you know an interesting way to it's
really hard to do like a randomized
control trial on something like this
plan
but a general idea would be that by
investing the ten minutes into something
like mindfulness would catalyze a
tremendously more productive next 40
minutes and then would to just exactly
yeah dive to earth exactly yep my
students told me that that they came to
class stressed yeah
ap kids will tell you how stressed they
are but all kids are stressed we don't
have stress right to some extent
oh gosh should I start talking about the
stress of my e else do this
yeah please I actually tell us about
yell I think that would that's one of
the topics that we should talk about
yeah this is another empathy this builds
a lot of empathy you're like you're
coming into
another place in the world and you want
to learn the language of that place in
the world that you're coming to and
getting behind their eyes and being like
well how can we most deeply respect and
teach towards that process and respect
culture too yeah so you know the stress
anxiety students come to school with can
it can be grades yeah it can be grandpa
and grandma's health right it could also
be ice as in immigration and raids it
could be the fear that dad won't be home
it could be memories of the trip from El
Salvador to the United States because
here in Sioux Falls South Dakota I have
students who were 14 15 16 years old
when they left Central America by
themselves and came to America it's
documented in Sonia nazario's book
Enrique's journey that woman god bless
her the work she's done those are my
students those are the stories they tell
me so there's things we need to honor
and give kids a chance to deal with and
learn how to manage right I think
someone once told me the best leaders
are able to manage their emotions so I
need to give them the tools to regulate
and manage so that they can be their
best selves and then back to the vision
have more options and opportunities in
life so yeah you know I will do whatever
I can whether it's yoga breathing just
some quiet time reflection time so that
you are exactly right so that their
minds are more ready to really absorb
absorb what we're gonna learn yep and
there's I mean the amountof of different
things that you've been doing as well so
it's not just the AP English language
composition
the sheltered English the teacher
pathway and the AP department chair what
would be some of the you know the key
points from those that you could share
with us sure the AP program I I left it
on purpose
it was my decision to leave the
department chair a role because I wanted
to be in the classroom more i i teach AP
and i believe in AP because it can give
kids more options and opportunities you
know i have students who go into college
as sophomores and because of that they
can get a double major they can go into
grad school earlier those kind of things
they get college a lot of credits at a
lower rate there are downsides to AP as
well that that exam is rigorous and it
costs a lot of money ninety five dollars
or so so so that's tough
but I left a peen mostly because I
wanted to be a students more I left the
AP department chair that's when I
started teaching my ei L students who
have taught me more than I have ever
taught them who come from Asia and I
really you know I really would like to
be more specific because that would be
maybe I well okay so last year I had a
student from Nepal a few students from
Ethiopia students from Sudan
Guatemala El Salvador Honduras yeah so
that's where our students are coming
from and I just I'm thankful that I get
to teach them and that they teach me so
much
but we haven't talked much about teacher
pathway yeah they also quick a bit about
the relationship between the student
that's coming here to learn English
language and then you and you're
learning from them and what they have to
teach and how that dynamic works I'm
learning that school has been set up
according to white culture the rules and
the policies fit into white culture and
that does so there are different ways of
doing things and those different ways
aren't necessarily wrong ways I'm just
doing whatever I can to honor my
students cultures and to learn from my
students and to help them to bring their
culture into the classroom I I I read a
book a couple years ago called push out
I think the subtitle is the criminai the
criminalization of black girls in our
schools and you know that's the best
thing we can do is just listen and read
and learn I'll never forget that book
talked about how there's some of our
black girls get in trouble for wearing
some sort of rap or hat to school right
but if you knew what it takes to get all
those braids in when the girls want
braids my my girls who get braids that
takes that's a two day project or an all
day Saturday project eight hours right
so they don't want to come to school
half braided so they're either gonna
come with a hat on and then get in
trouble and get detention or whatever or
just not come to school at all and
that's just one example of things where
we're not recognizing the culture and
then we end up punishing kids it's
really unfair
can you believe their schools who don't
allow don't allow dreadlocks why what
the heck
I don't get it I don't get it so what
would be the argument is a something
related though I suppose probably you
know a school might be wanting to create
a professional atmosphere but still I
don't know how that doesn't fit well
what do you think would be the argument
I don't know
wait you know there was the rustle or
did you hear about the wrestler who was
forced to cut his dreadlocks off so he
can wrestle oh wow Wow
no I'm sure there's something I don't
know right maybe it was dangerous yeah I
did I believe that's what it is so that
you can't be pulled by yeah your hair
regardless to make the school's most
conducive for people's fullest
expression unique expression I think
that's critical okay and then let's do
teacher pathways - okay this is not my
brainchild but I am all on board so dr.
Donald Easton Brooks who was the dean of
education at University of South Dakota
USD he's now at the University of Nevada
at Reno had this idea and his heart is
to try to inspire more diversity in our
teaching force teaching workforce which
I love that idea like almost all
teachers are just like me middle-aged
white women who grew up in a
middle-class lifestyle and I'm doing the
best I can to empathize and learn about
my kids but it's not the same as
somebody who grew up like my students
right students need to see role models
who look like them yeah yeah yeah there
you go
so and this doesn't mean that it ruins
hiring practices and that kind of thing
we just want to give people of color a
chance to interview right or inspire
them to get the degree so anyhow dr.
Easton Brooks came to the Sioux Falls
School District and said I'd like to try
to inspire students to become teachers
one day so a future teachers type of
club or class
and he had seen a model of it out on the
west coast but we didn't try to mimic or
follow another model we created it on
our own for the needs of this this place
so the stoop of school district was on
board every high school are for public
high schools has a teacher pathway
teacher and offers to teacher pathway
classes and the purpose is to inspire
the next generation of teachers to give
them a jumpstart on teaching because
they can get up to three college credits
by taking that class while in high
school and you know part of my job is to
let students know that teaching is an
awesome career yeah right I think from
media perhaps they get the idea that if
you become a teacher you're gonna live
in poverty and students have told me
that we have a club called Black Student
Union at Roosevelt and I go to a lot of
different clubs at Roosevelt and just
talk about hey think about taking
teacher pathway well I went to that Club
I said have any of you ever thought of
being a teacher
not one not one there were probably 20
kids in the room not even thought about
it did you ever think about being a
teacher didn't even cross your mind for
a minute yes yeah exactly
so I said why not and they said we want
money we don't want to be poor all our
lives
and you know I said let me tell you what
my reality is not gonna be the richest
person in Sioux Falls South Dakota not
gonna be over wealthy but I have a very
nice middle-class lifestyle I have
security I have a great retirement plan
great benefits it's a good good life and
so I'm trying to educate kids that can
make it an option it may be it's your
second option or third option but let's
explore it hey let's explore what it is
to be a teacher while you're in high
school so when you get to college you're
not wasting time there yeah most of my
students my teacher pathway students I'd
about 45 last year got more
fire for being a teacher but there were
a few who said whoa this is not what I
thought it was yeah this is not for me I
don't like standing up in front of
groups of people yeah yeah maybe
counseling would be good for you or some
other told ya
whoa so even just dipping fingers into
the waters of teaching younger ages just
so that they can get the feeling for it
and just making it an option putting it
on the tool belt of possibilities love
it I love how you said that we're just
giving them other options and and
helping them yeah make some decisions
yes okay and then back one back when I
was a student with you were there there
was only how many AP classes were there
like in the whole school you know
knowing these are AP English classes oh
gosh when you were med student there
were probably full three-year I probably
taught three or four three or four
uh-huh yeah okay so then it slowly went
up - yeah - five and then a hundred and
twenty students now - eeeep English so
it's kind of like you were you were a
spark for so many young people to want
to study literature more deeply or like
to care more about English or to care
more about this your methodologies that
we've been talking about throughout I
also want to say that you know you
talked about this a little bit but this
idea of culturally responsive teaching
you didn't mention this a couple times
about these students coming from around
the world and meeting students that were
there at you you were doing you've been
doing things so well that just about
four years ago you got the Milken
educator award in 2015 I watched the
video of you get it and I watched it you
know watch it's hard to watch yourself
on video but you probably have to do it
all the time now
you were you were great actually when
you were receiving the ward I was also
feeling but living vicariously through
you and through your experience it was a
really beautiful because you had
invested so much of your time in essence
into into other students and in doing
things really well that it was super
well deserved it's great that they got
that so then what was that experience
then that was Milken educator awards are
given yearly to about 40 teachers in the
nation mm-hmm
it is not anything I applied for I
didn't know I'd been nominated so it's a
complete surprise and you can see that
in my reaction so yeah they tell us
we're having an assembly to talk about
dual credit in South Dakota and we walk
in and you see all these dignitaries if
you will sitting in the front of the gym
and you're thinking what is up here and
there's TV cameras and you know
something's yeah not what they told us
it would be and the Secretary of
Education stands up and starts talking
about dual credit and then says but
that's not really why I'm here
and they start describing this teacher
who's gonna win an award and they say
that the award isn't just an award but
it's money and then they have the kid
some kids holding up numbers and it
looks like it's a $250 reward and
everyone's like cool and then nope
another zero it's 2,500 and there was
like wow and then they make it $25,000
reward and wow that's pretty cool you
know um so anyhow they called my name
the person sitting next to me said I
think it's you and I said I think it's
you and and I had a few other ideas in
mind too I had any like a list of five
teachers I thought it probably would be
but it was me I didn't know what to say
you know they wanted me to talk and I
I hope I said something well cuz I
haven't watched it but what if you think
that you think the kids you did what you
did there why I do what I do I love what
I do but here's the deal you know very
quickly what are you gonna do with that
twenty five thousand dollars
well after taxes it pretty much paid for
a new furnace and my kids braces and
then the money is gone yeah the money is
so transient it's so temporary it's not
what the award is yeah right it gets the
attention so we can show that teaching
is an awesome profession to our
community right but the honor of being a
Milken educator is the networking yeah
and the opportunities milk and provides
me with so you know they're helping me
do a webinar next month about gradeless
classrooms know about teacher pathway
I've got two passions I've got two
passions so I'm doing the teacher
pathway one next month and they you know
they help me put my writing out there
and and the woman who gave me my award
Jane fought dr. Jane Foley best soul
ever shielded she's called me just so
you know to check up on some things but
like she's there for me you know she's
there for me if I if I need her and so
Milken activates educators to be the
best they can be
yeah yeah yeah they impart they see
something in the person and think we
would like to empower you it was
life-changing yeah yeah my I was feeling
goosebumps and just beautiful spirit
when I was watching your your your
accepting of the award and so okay so
then that that happened and there to
continue to activate more and more
teachers every year and showcase that I
love that you're doing a webinar with
them in September
on teacher pathways okay and then let's
talk on the mindful grading with great
lists yeah so what is that okay I'll
give you my backstory I love my job and
so it was December of 2016 2017 let me
think here
2017 I was sitting in my usual room
where I grade papers or do lesson plans
and my family was in the living room a
little bit away and I could hear them
laughing and enjoying time together and
I took a breath and thought I should be
bonding with my family I shouldn't be
working constantly and that I took that
to heart luckily I love podcast you
listen to podcast love podcast podcast
yes so I listen to music anymore hardly
mm-hmm so anyhow yeah let's get that
download of knowledge okay exactly you
know some podcasts are like music to my
ears
rob bell the rob cast I could just
listen to it like music anyhow I was
listening to cult of pedagogy with
Jennifer Gonzalez she was interviewing
Starr sax team who does not give grade
she's a high school English teacher in
New York or was she's moved on to more
leadership but anyhow more leadership I
I don't know if I want to say it that
way but she's she's still in education
leading in different ways anyhow she
talked about her great this classroom
she slide to give a grade on a
transcript a semester grade but no
grades otherwise I thought that's how I
can get more time no grades alright
it didn't take me more than a couple
months cuz III went right in I thought
I'm gonna do this next semester yeah
okay I knew I couldn't do it fully right
like that would take some work with my
district to me to say I'm not giving any
more grades but you know I can wade in
these waters I'm not gonna dive in but I
can wade in these waters I'm gonna do it
right now
well it didn't take me long to realize
that it didn't necessarily decrease my
workload but the work was so much more
fulfilling and meaningful to the
students and the students were so
grateful for how I restructured things
give less emphasis to grades and more
emphasis to feedback and growth and
reflection and and that's an important
thing to me that's not just the teacher
giving students feedback but the
students are giving the teacher feedback
so I would have moments where we'd start
class and I'd say how is this working
for you all all right have a more
specific question and we they would give
me the feedback I needed to make sure
I'm giving them what they need so how
does it work
it looks different in every classroom so
here's how it looks in my classroom
students will have maybe up to ten
grades for the whole semester and in the
grade book to compare I used to probably
have closer to well you know at one
point in my career probably fifty grades
mm-hmm in a semester I just would slowly
whittle that down over the years because
that you should never grade practice but
I used to use grading as my classroom
management tool mm-hmm
relationships should be the classroom
management tool relationships should
help you with behaviors not worksheets
practice exercises from a textbook
that's not a classroom management tool
that's manipulation that's unethical in
my opinion so as I started not grading
practice more and more and more my
grading day go down but now it's just
you know standards-based you could say
where it's what you see in the grade
book are not specific events that
happened or assignments that happened
but a skill that needs to be learned
argumentative writing needs to be
learned and the score that gets put
there can change as we keep practicing
throughout the semester that's a key
mm-hmm when you are trying to grade less
so they're getting immediate feedback
from you in a dialogue about how they're
doing and what they can keep working on
they're teaching you as well and okay
then their grade is also improving as
they continue leveling up and getting
better at that specific and then that
grade is what they go with at the end
you're right because that is not fair
that the grade should be an average of
where they were along in where they were
in the journey the great should be where
they what the destination is the great
should show the destination not the
journey hmm right interesting yeah
whichever one always says it's all about
the journey or in a class it should be
where they ended all the struggle along
the way averaging scores throughout the
whole semester hmm no yeah versus what
they actually are at the very end what
they've taken away yeah yeah you can see
it you could have a student who gets to
that a level at the end but really
struggled early on and ends up with a B
mm-hm that's just not right mmm-hmm it's
not right interesting so then okay so
then so this has been implemented by you
I think almost two years then three
semesters where yeah
so then what has it been like then
sharing this with other teachers and
their feedback yeah so the first thing I
have to always say is that the movement
in education is great this classroom
that's the name of it in project-based
learning as well that's it that's it
yeah
yes very good that's so age one yeah so
I've been recently saying that there
shouldn't it's kind of crazy that like
what would be better education than
project-based learning around things
like the sustainable development annals
like really that's kind of what
education should be is teaching around
the most important less of the most
important goals of society striving to
solve or to accomplish if your listeners
want a good book to read on
project-based learning it would be what
schools could be by Ted denter Smith
mmm-hmm
actually have you read it Hey oh it's so
good anyhow let's see so great those
classrooms a lot of times they just they
end up being grade less not great list
but grade less yeah because you know of
having to fall into the policies and
regulations of a school district that
they might
but you know what does it mean it means
we're not grading practice we are not
grading behaviors late work you know
okay here are we gonna we we're okay
with penalizing a student's grade
because something was late but we don't
penalize a great if a student swears at
me in class yeah okay so I'd behavioral
stuff like late work or bringing in
Kleenex for the classroom bringing in
food for the food drive should not be
reflected in the grade then it creates a
dishonest grade the grade should reflect
the skill level mm-hmm now what if a
student comes in with you you're you
were always really bright right you you
were already at a high skill level can
you just take a final test or write a
final essay and be done no you got to
produce enough evidence there has to be
evidence so gradeless doesn't mean
students aren't doing anything but no
way my students are doing more than ever
because they have to produce the
evidence to justify whatever the final
grade is on the transcript yeah mm-hmm
so what else
but gradeless classrooms for things have
to emphasize growth emphasize feedback
so that's why my job didn't get easier
because feedback moves from being a
letter or a number which really means
nothing to being actual words words yes
mm-hmm yeah actually new when you're
sitting in your grading space in your in
your home and you hear your family
you're yes you can hopefully go and
attend to them more but you still have
to have a personalized for every single
student like feedback in growth
closed-loop system where you're ready to
go in the next day with certain ideas
for how to
yeah it's still which I'm so excited
about the future of Education these
closed-loop feedback systems are
critical for growth when you're getting
like any immediate like dialogue about
how to improve rather than having a way
to tell teacher circles are excess off
things and gives you a numbered score at
the end yeah yeah the thing about you
know whatever grades you do end up
putting in the grading system in a in
gradeless philosophy there really never
frozen until the very end we can always
change those scores to show growth
that's been happening and if we are in a
system of grading that doesn't allow for
hope mm-hmm why would students challenge
themselves
it might that's what my AP students are
only ready already at this level I don't
know if I can make it to the last part
and do well versus I know that I'm
always in this journey towards the end
and I know that that I can still put in
good work and still yeah and here's the
other thing my AP students said when I
wasn't grading very much they were more
willing to take on challenges and risks
with their learning mm-hmm because
they're smart well everybody's smart in
different ways but they're smart to know
that well I better play it safe to hold
my 4.0 GPA yeah I better play it safe
that are saying risk which can then lead
you to more beautiful ways of growth
yeah exactly exactly so to sum it up
quickly in two different ways
the gradeless classroom is not about
transactions but transformation and
secondly the gradeless classroom means
that I have a Learning Lab not a grading
game yeah that's great a Learning Lab
instead of a grading game yeah yeah I
like that yeah and that's why I stopped
being the AP department chair because I
wanted to be back in the lab a
transformation Learning Lab oh gosh I
love it
I want to do experiments I want to test
hypotheses I'm an English teacher but we
do that in English too right we
experiment with our writing hey let me
try some parallelism here oh yeah that's
great
now shorten it up yeah mm-hmm it's cool
and if you really like science you can
write more about science if you really
like history you can write more about
history it's great that you can kind of
look yeah any writing is so applicable
to everything that we do readings so
applicable to everything that we do as
humans and so to build up a larger
vocabulary set abrade a greater ability
to be able to read faster parse four key
points all these types of things type
faster what not just all gonna help you
become better and better in the fields
that you pursue whatever that ends up
being what I love about the English
classroom and literature is it delves
into the human condition and there are
not always easy black and white answers
yeah we have to go into the gray area we
have to and we want and we have to
listen to both sides yeah and so for
reading and for writing I tell my kids
if you couldn't write something for both
sides of whatever issue it is you
haven't studied it and now if you
haven't thought about enough yeah I
should be able to say okay the topic is
immigration
okay draw draw draw draw black like a a
note card one of the note cards says
you're for it or for reform one of these
look yeah what kind of what are your
feelings on coin flip there you go and
you could that's what it used to be in
yeah there you go yep and you could do
either essay that's where I want to get
them because we need to have civil
discourse and we can't have that if
we're not listening to all sides yeah
listen
yeah you know having an understanding of
how and take a given issue like
healthcare whatever what have you and
then if you try and you try and not only
like crunch how 8 billion people view
health care from their unique
respective than you learn when like a
rich and poor think or what a certain
religion thinks or what a certain age
thinks of a person or yeah certain place
of birth in the world like so you gives
you a greater propensity to get behind
people's eyes and understand how they
see certain things and also it's a we're
plagued by cognitive ease where we just
want a binary answer like want to be
enlightened in five minutes but we took
10 years to learn language and so it's
like you know there's gonna be things
that you have to invest deeper amounts
of time in to understand the complexity
of and then then you can better reduce
[Music]
English definitely does that and I'm
happy that you care so much about having
them see both sides of that and of that
conversation I don't think I got to
finish what Grail is classrooms have to
be I think I said good growth I said
feedback yes
okay so then there also have to be
relevant authentic assessments yes and
let's give them authentic experiences
things that feel meaningful okay not
worksheets well I guess I shouldn't say
never maybe there's a good one out there
but yeah yeah relevant meaningful work
and then lastly kids need to some
autonomy some agency they need to be
able to make some of their own decisions
have a voice yeah right that's what and
you know in you kind of alluded to this
the beauty of teaching English is they
can write about so many different things
yeah right I'm not gonna sign an essay
that just makes it so that all my
students turn in the same topic yeah
oh gosh yeah I already hate reading yeah
yeah I do love giving feedback yeah I do
love a conversation but I hate putting a
number or a letter scores that's
interesting so you kind of fall in love
with the dialogue of the students growth
and the feedback of their growth versus
the the scoring or numbered numbering or
a lettering don't test yeah I like that
too and that's also what education has
been like since the dawn of time is the
transmission of wisdom from people that
were older and wiser and then it would
be like okay now demonstrate what what
it is it's like okay great you were able
to alright here's the next activity you
weren't okay let's go an immediate
feedback for growth to to help you here
well maybe this isn't the right activity
maybe we should do a different format of
learning maybe you are interested in a
different subject or field or whatever
maybe it was never like it here's an 86
because yeah and what does an 86 mean
right yeah one teacher gives a 95 one
two Gs in 75 or whatever yeah based on
this stuff yeah okay so what about your
relationship with the divine you
recently used the word contemplatively
liked I would use that in my latest blog
post you know I love that when I started
teaching and when I had kids I I was an
English teacher because I loved reading
and writing and I love students of
course but I never read or wrote I read
my students papers I wrote comments and
gave them feedback but I never read or
wrote like how I wanted to and as my own
kids have gotten older I'm coming back
to that I'm on my 10th book this summer
in October so about ten months ago I
started a blog called leaving church org
which it's something I had to put out
there but my regret is that I can't
really share it with my students right
because I don't want to create any
barriers between my students and me due
to faith and religion aspects but anyhow
the question was the divine
contemplative so I couldn't do the
normal American church anymore and that
might just be my personality right I it
might be really great for some people it
probably it's really great for my sister
like she loves it and I I'm glad for
that right but I couldn't do the
marketing the hierarchy mmm the budgets
anyhow so my husband was in the same
place and you know to to put it all out
there in the church we'd attended for
two decades things didn't go as we had
hoped when we had a child in the
congregation transition female to male
mmhmm yeah
yeah I just a name and gender right
you're not talking about surgery for a
12 year old but I wasn't 12 actually but
a child and my husband I said now we
can't do this we thought do we stay and
try to provide other perspective yeah we
ended up going a different route so we
we left the typical American Church and
now we meet with a few other families
once a week and we talk about the divine
we talk about the Jesus tradition we're
all in the Jesus tradition we'll read
from a book and discuss that so it's a
lot like book club right some people
call it home church and I just I don't I
think people get the wrong image with
that because we're not singing hymns and
nobody's preaching a sermon it's more
like book club yeah so or we'll do a
piece of Scripture that we're going to
talk about and we make sure to integrate
the kids so the kids are in there with
us and talking with us and it's
intergenerational which is really really
cool so
in making that shift in my life
it has leaving Church has brought me
closer to the divine to God mm-hmm yeah
because I I'm totally responsible for
myself now mm-hmm right like I can't
depend on the pastor I can't depend on
the Bible study I need to make it happen
and also leaving church means my Sunday
mornings are open because we get
together on Wednesday nights or Saturday
nights as our group and so and I should
tell you the group you know it's not
it's not just a bunch of rebels who are
looking to you know fight the system
there's two former pastors in our group
two former pastors so anyhow we just
love studying scripture thinking about
God we don't always agree on things yeah
you know but but that's okay because the
most important thing is that we love God
love each other that kind of thing yeah
and a grown closer to God because and I
have my Sunday well many reasons but I
love my Sunday mornings just sit on the
deck and be quiet or because we're in
South Dakota and when it's 20 below oh
sit in my front room with a big window
and let the Sun Shine on me yeah just be
quiet and open up and this is where the
contemplative part comes in that you
asked about just open up that space for
whatever right you know just find some
peace
have faith find that faith because I
don't you got to admit the whole idea of
the divine God it it's really hard to
prove right
and so yeah then so I love the doubts
that we talk about in our group the
questions we talk about because that
only makes the idea of faith real mm-hmm
yeah we don't just throw around the word
faith yeah it's real yeah so this is
great this more in a sense it's like
rather than falling into like a dogmatic
or a undock just a system that
indoctrinates yeah without the process
of self-discovery or self-reflection or
self contemplation and connection
individually with the divine but rather
it's almost like it's being preached to
us a specific way or there's being Dogma
ties in ways that's not as conducive to
this actual adventure of consciousness
and spiritually communing with that so I
like that I like what that this essence
of what we're talking about is kind of
further being passed along it seems as
though that that is that's this kind of
like new these new feelings that people
are having around the world now is have
it yeah is that this is kind of where
the transmission is moving to I tell you
what as I've gone into this now we're
gonna be starting the third year of our
group and this is not a very unique
thing there are and I'll use a term home
church but there are home churches all
over and my tribe is big I'm finding on
Twitter in books Rachel held Evans who
else Sarah Bessie Rob Bell Richard burr
are you know these people are
articulating in books and in podcasts
what I felt in my heart for so long and
giving me words to what seems so true to
me
but I again have to say that's not to
say that the church experience is bad
for everybody right or wrong for people
especially for my kids my kids go to a
normal churches for Wednesday night
youth group it's it's a good foundation
builder for them it's been good it's
what they want and that's cool that's
cool but then they also experience what
we do at our home church they're getting
both yeah and I have a I have dear
friends who who connect with God so well
in the church whatever take your own
path to commune with the divine however
it is yeah right yeah yeah don't kill
anyone along the please yeah oh yeah
like all along the way yeah oh my gosh
the way that churches have hurt people
yeah which usually get swept under the
rug yeah and yeah and probably all
faiths have done it you know but what's
our expiry look yeah let's wrap with a
couple thoughts one is what is your
thinking around if we come as spirit to
meet the body for these adventures and
consciousness mm-hmm I'm gonna say two
things there so make sure I say the two
things um was wasn't meister eckhart or
Eckhart Tolle I don't know who said it
but we are not human beings having a
spiritual experience but spiritual
beings having a human experience and I
feel that I can't explain it but that
resonates yeah
I feel that right now because I think
God's all about community yeah
what happened ten years ago I took your
class got it really inspired by you
became a better student and not ten
years later we have a show for
interviewing you yeah it's just the
blessing that teachers get to see what
all their students end up doing well
Facebook this is that reason this
doesn't seem like just a human thing
that seems like a way deeper spiritual
synchronicity that's happening yeah I
feel sacred you're sure and so yeah I
think God is all about community you
said union with the divine for yoga yeah
exactly and I think the instead of using
no I don't know how I want to say this
exactly but where it goes wrong is when
there's separation
yeah right we are experiencing the
illusion of separation that's why some
spiritual leaders say that the earth is
such a cool place that so many spirits
want to come and potentially be human at
is because it's one of the coolest
places to experience the illusion of
separation from sources the divine unity
the oneness oh wow yeah so you know
instead of saying the word sin I'm not
saying the word sin is a word which
aren't used okay but I like to think of
it as separation because a lot of things
we do that people characterize as sin
what they did is they separated us from
community in some way right okay so the
other thing I wanted to say I remember
going to college and I went to a small
liberal arts Christian college had to
take my Bible classes and Christian
thought class presented this idea to me
that the Bible has a lot of metaphor in
it
it's not maybe all entirely 100% fact
has happened in history yeah right it
might you know some of us a piece of
literature poetry don't worry poetry
story myth and legend write all to teach
us two important important things yeah
yeah yeah so as that notion has taken
written me this idea has also taken root
and that's that and it's a metaphor it's
a metaphor I feel like God is would be
like the ocean okay
just infinite water yeah yeah and I am a
vessel and in that vessel is a mixture
of water and oil okay the things where I
am in separation from God and humanity
would be the oil the things where I am
in connection and union with God in
humanity mm-hmm that's the water and
mean and I want that vessel to be all
water I would love for that the hard
thing to do it's hard to clear the
channel to be fully conducive with water
yeah okay ultimately the oil is access
our lessons soil our big lessons for us
is faith sometimes we're Delta card that
has trauma or a trigger and our
treasures are on the other side but we
have to integrate really absolutely
interesting okay so my vessel can have
bearing amounts of water and oil it's
not all constant right yes yeah and when
my life is done the vessel is poured out
into the ocean I like that yeah and I am
in totally in
the presence of the divine of God and
another one is that then the amount of
like self work that we've done to sort
of clear out some of the oil or
integrate and make as much water as we
can then we're contributing to this
collective a human experience with more
water as it gets poured out versus if
you if you just if you're just a massive
pile of oil at the very end you never
found out who you who you are what your
gifts are or maybe unknowingly
sociopathic to society
the poor oil back and then you'll
butterfly effect it out of mmm
negativity I love that yet you know this
conversation
I love having these conversations this
feels really sacred to you too yeah yeah
but I gotta tell you I have a little bit
of fear when I have these conversations
and it's on camera right because this is
not not not what I was this is not the
language that was used in my growing up
years right mmm the ways I think about
God know and love God and just rest in
God now sound hippie trippy to people
some people in my past right and I I
don't this is great you're adding more
to your worldview you're making it more
robust well round in I that's yeah and
so I just I could be wrong on things
right now this just this really works
really really well you're on your own
path and you took some good stuff from
who you were growing up and what you
were learning and you learn some new
things later on in your life and you've
been adding them to your own experience
of the divine and shouldn't be that you
will any any time that we try and put
everyone's communion with the divine
through the same round circle a circular
hole or square hole then that's when
that's what some of the whole thing with
these religious texts from around the
world as epic as so many of them are if
there's no flexibility with people
union with this what's sacred to them
then for certain people they want to
commune in a way that aligns with their
style of life and the way that they
behave anyway it's yeah so yeah so I
just want to freely admit that I don't
know at all
likewise and you know in a in a few
years I might have different ideas and I
think we all do
I will evolve yeah I will you all right
sure hope I evolve yeah and so I'm just
doing the best I can right now yeah I'm
trying to love God and love others and
take care of myself self I love them
what a great way to to wrap on that
whole circle ending full circle I think
I thought that yeah okay that was such a
critical part of writing it would be so
funny when you'd like start writing and
you'd have to say beautiful like plot
like you'd you'd have this beautiful
formation of a story that you're telling
and then you'd basically figure out how
to in a sense make the reader that was
initially reading from the very
beginning go aha I see how cool they
just wrapped it all together and that's
like just tighten it up like a nice bow
yes yeah and like you can do that
through your writing through the video
through the way you articulate things
you people will see how you basically
plant seeds and then later at the very
end they're like whoa look at all the
fruits that that had cuz you were
frequently watering it throughout yeah I
love that use the planting seeds
metaphor Alan it's been it's a big one
for me yeah because you know I don't
want to get into political arguments of
people I don't want to get into
religious arguments which I don't want
to debate with anybody really but you
know I just I'll plant some seeds and
they might grow they might not yeah and
that's just where I leave it I I've
released that stress of trying to try
trying to convince people of anything
likewise and I'll just just plant some
seeds likewise is great yeah
yeah that's super on that same beat so
what are your thoughts about the this
crude this experience of creation that
that we're all a part of what would you
say is the meaning or the purpose of it
community and I think it's why I teach
English so that we can we read we read
so we can be better for ourselves and
for society we write so we can be better
for ourselves in society you see that in
my leaving church org blog I'm I'm
writing also for me to make sense of the
spiritual transformation happening in my
life and I'm hoping that that I connect
with a few people who feel the same way
I feel so our ultimate purpose if I
understand your question right is like
to be better for ourselves and other
people yeah yeah yeah what do you think
well stand on the shoulders of giants
and so it just seems like a lot of the
good thoughts are on to have been about
maximizing consciousness or maximizing
creativity or maximizing experiencing
the divine right having the divine fully
realize itself through us propagating
more creations ourselves so once we
understand the source code of where we
live we can then start more of it
ourselves do you think we're in a
simulation I don't really know what you
mean by that way you explained that so
once you would understand something like
the the source code of the reality that
we reside in could
and start our own creation and then
embed consciousness within that creation
have it grown complexity and then have
it self realize itself that process it's
a very cyclical this is just one one
experience of creation I do I think if I
understand it correctly I'd like to
explore that more with you sometime I'd
also want to explain it better yeah it's
important what do you think for me to
explain it better I've been enjoying
this Ouroboros theory of source recently
where it's likely you linearly evolved
from like from source to atoms and stars
and planets and single-cell multi-cell
or is it the humans to the massive
civilization that we have and then we
become so smart we realized the source
code and then we're able to basically
wrap and start again which goes from the
simplicity from source single simple
itself and then that process just keeps
happening and so linear time is rejected
linear causality is rejected and it's
just all happening and then that's our
and so then when people kind of maybe
like experience the anxiety around
things that in itself can seem like it's
a symptom of not spiritually communing
with that theory of source cuz if you
were communing really well with that
what source you probably wouldn't be
experiencing that amount of anxiety
about the past of the future or even the
president but just being and being with
this flow of the universe the dow is
flow some of what you said resonates
with me like i I get the whole the word
flow is so perfect for
Mikan template to the path or whatever
but there was something you said that
did not resonate with me I don't
remember what it was anymore that's okay
this is great and this is the way we
have you know just conversation about
these things and open-mindedness and
yeah love for one another yeah that
that's - there's a great point like I
don't know if I agree with all of that
but I still loved it I so love it love
you still love it yeah love you too it's
good yeah it's exactly what enough yeah
what a way to teach young people how to
have conversations with each other
Oh what do you think the most beautiful
thing in the world
hey my kids so cliche right just say my
children it is amazing and it's one of
the reasons that I have my faith because
humans were created inside of me yeah
exactly
I think that's amazing amazing and so
what he savart the body is yes it just
yeah my kids are beautiful but if I will
be on the cliche what is beautiful
sitting in silence in community with God
Devine
yeah I love that yeah oh that's so good
silence with just for me it feels like a
bunch of light from different people all
in that community being shot up through
the crown and up and that then that like
matrix of communion all happening at the
same time is yeah you can feel it when
you're amongst other people that are you
know that are really community and you
can feel it I feel like radiated [ __ ]
yeah I have friends like that
I can feel it pull over I'm so lucky to
have the tribe I have yeah yeah that's
great yeah that's another one is having
people around you that are can also
bring that light to your life and that
yeah this has been so awesome I can't
believe that like you know ten years ago
then being a student in your class and
then and then only now like really
realizing how important the teachers
were in our lives our parents were in
sacrificing what they did to make our
lives happen and all the people before
us that built the world that we have I
mean in connecting deeper with source
and our gifts like it's it's interesting
seeing you know seeing what happens in
just a decade of time with with even
with adults later on in their life they
transformed so much as well because also
you were in so many ways so much more
different than what you know yeah and I
love connecting with former students and
showing the
that I am I think I'm getting better
with time
I love getting older Allen likewise
right you know like people say oh yeah
it's my 29th birthday again ok fine you
know it's cute and funny but no I am 41
years old I've turned 42 next month and
I love it because it's it's experienced
its increased understanding and there's
only more to come excited for all the
next year's and meanwhile axilla can
Valley and tech sectors trying to take
your library that you've stored in your
mind and they're trying to keep it
forever so that way there's never gonna
be a moment when we don't know what
happened with your life or so that way
maybe in the future it would be cool to
be able to preserve these libraries of
consciousness and see how maybe maybe
something should just be forgotten and
that's it do you have anything that
should be forgotten no no cuz you learn
from everything I learned for everything
I've no regrets right I love that stuff
I would love to open source it and just
let other people learn from it and let
myself go back and learn the lessons
again as needed you know that type of
stuff so did you learn from the pranks
you did in high school
or do you just laugh I don't know just
fine I do I laugh but it's still um it's
still it's funny looking back at it and
realizing how what you know what growth
is and for me like growing up from that
like also is uh you know recently as
well it's like I just I just don't care
so much about drug use used to be so
much more proclivity towards alcohol or
cannabis or psychedelics or whatever in
the last couple years has just been like
screw all of that stuff it doesn't mean
as much to me as my divine relationship
every single day when I wake up and when
I go to bed and what gifts that I want
to bring to the world and share with
other people and that has nothing to do
with those substances and so so anyway
it's been like a growth of like not
really caring so much and then caring
more about things that were like
transient or things like that like you
gratification experiences that type of
stuff and so I'm still working on it
still whole process myself work because
my gosh like you know sugars addictive
and and and there's so many other things
and if so many things are dated now the
way to me the way that we just sit I use
it so how we need under dict
ourselves from those processes and the
algorithms are really deep enough so
it's a constant work in progress
yeah we have to be very intentional
other ways we're going out of my way
teachers to go on autopilot right we can
just do what we were but we always
experienced the students which wasn't
always bad but sometime to us in when we
can be intentional and mindful about
what we do in the classroom and those
people to go to autopilot and hop on
Facebook or
because I'm stressed or sick until
seems like the core idea of mindful
teaching can be applied with so many
methodologies NASA students and you've
shared a ton of them with us yeah
conversation is in time absolutely yeah
going and growing back thank you thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let us know what you're thinking
also check out the links in the bio
below to Geena Ben's not work as well as
leaving church Oregon her Twitter
profile have more conversations for your
friends families co-workers people
online about mindful teaching mindful
grading all the other topics that we
talked about today and also support the
artists the entrepreneurs the leaders in
your communities that you believe and
support them and help them grow support
simulation our links are below as well
you find us on patreon PayPal
cryptocurrency or you can design cool
merch and get paid all those links are
below and also go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world and we love you very much thank
you for tuning in and we will see you
soon I'm stay
[Music]
you
[Music]